[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen wo die zahme
ist auch dabei für den sport hallo guten
amt und das sind einige unserer themen
heute
gleich zwei rote linien die fdp sagt ihr
generalsekretär wissing wird weder
steuererhöhungen noch das lockern der
schuldenbremse mittragen
teures schmuckstück die gorch fock ist
wieder in schuss 135 millionen euro hat
die sanierung des segelschulschiffs der
bundeswehr gekostet und nobelpreis für
medizin zwei us forscher haben
herausgefunden wie genau unsere haut
hitze kälte und berührung spürt
[Musik]
rot grün gelb mit olaf scholz als
bundeskanzler oder schwarz grün gelb mit
armin laschet eine woche nach der wahl
ist offen wer das land künftig regiert
gestern gab es einen ganzen reigen an
zweiergesprächen jetzt drückt die spd
aufs tempo will schnell mit grünen und
fdp reden und bekommt erste dämpfer die
liberalen beharren im gegensatz zu spd
und grünen auf roten linien aus berlin
daniel johnston
eigentlich stand heute eine art ruhetag
an doch als das politische berlin heute
erwarte zeichnete sich im zdf
morgenmagazin sanft aber eindeutig das
ende der bisherigen flirt atmosphäre ab
in der spd will 12 euro mindestlohn wir
sagen dass wir wohnen bezahlbar machen
wir wollen stabile renten aber der sinn
von verhandlungen ist der zu gucken wo
sind schnittmengen es geht jetzt gar
nicht darum rote linien zu formulieren
genau das aber tat die fdp formulierte
gleich zwei rote linien beibehalten der
schuldenbremse und keine
steuererhöhungen die fdp hat das klar
gesagt und die fdp rückt von dieser
position auch nicht ab das ist eine
klare aussage gewesen ähnlich klar steht
im spd-programm wir werden eine
einkommenssteuerreform vornehmen die
kleine und mittlere einkommen besser
stellt und dafür im gegenzug die oberen
fünf prozent stärker heranzieht es ist
also bewegung gefragt dass sich fdp und
union nicht nur hier näher sind war
bekannt wenig überraschend daher die
positive bewertung ihre ersten gespräche
abend wir haben ein gemeinsames
verständnis in diesem gespräch
geschaffen dass etwas neues entstehen
muss weil die herausforderung so groß
sind dass auch nur mit neuen ansätzen
diese großen aufgaben für die zukunft
deutschlands bewältigt werden können für
ein solches jamaika-bündnis wiederum
wäre ein aufeinander zubewegen richtung
grüne nötig die ihrerseits gestern mit
dem ihnen traditionell näher stehenden
partner der spd sanierten wir haben auch
bei der spd eine bereitschaft gefunden
und festgestellt tatsächlich noch einmal
neu zu starten eine dynamik zu entfachen
die dann ja auch die liegengebliebenen
probleme vielleicht lösen kann morgen
vormittag nun treffen grüne und union
erstmals zusammen die frage auch da
wieviel flirt und wie viele
konfliktlinien zutage treten
fragen wir wieder theo koll sofort
versuchen und konfliktlinien was es da
heute am ruhetag heraus zu hören
und zu hören war eine mischung aus
leisen tönen aber es gab auch eben den
beschriebenen paukenschlag des fdp
generalsekretärs der noch einmal sehr
deutlich die roten linien für die
liberalen klar gemacht hat zwar
schwirren auch schon diverse vorschläge
hierdurch berlin die beispielsweise
diese schuldenbremse dann doch
regelgerecht durch eine art externe
fonds zu umgehen wäre aber die betonung
von roten linien scheint auch ein
bewusstes signal an spd und grüne
gewesen zu sein achtung es ist uns ernst
mit unserem programm bei der union hofft
man jetzt dass armin laschet die ihm
zugeschriebene stärke ausspielen kann
als verhandler der anderen raum und der
folge zugesteht das gespräch gestern
dauerte mit der union eine stunde länger
als geplant was als gutes zeichen
gewertet wird übrigens auch dass es ohne
mobiltelefone stattfand es entscheidende
gespräche aber dürfte das morgige union
grüne werden dann entscheidet sich wie
es insgesamt weitergeht
dankeschön nach berlin theo koll
die sogenannten pandora papers bringen
weltweit politiker und prominente in
erklärungsnot ein internationales
recherche netzwerk zeigt anhand dieser
daten wer wie wo massiv steuern
vermieden hat zum beispiel über
briefkastenfirmen in der karibik genannt
werden unter anderem der ukrainische
präsident zielinski der britische
ex-premier player und jordaniens könig
abdullah der zweite insgesamt mehr als
330 teils hochrangige politiker in
tschechien muss sich regierungschef
barbies kritische fragen gefallen lassen
britta hilpert
das ist doch ein gutes timing sagt andré
barbisch ironisch kurz nachdem bekannt
wurde dass er französische immobilien
über briefkastenfirmen kaufte in einer
wahl debatte vermutet er ja eine
verschwörung
fünf tage vor der wahl veröffentlichen
journalisten die meine gegner bezahlen
dass sie 2009 10 sind welche immobilien
kaufte ein internationales investigativ
netzwerk deckte auf dass barbisch in
frankreich unter anderem ein schloss auf
verschleierten weg für 15 millionen euro
kaufte es sei versteuertes geld gewesen
sagt barbisch eine maklerin habe ihm den
kauf über anwälte empfohlen wozu
briefkastenfirmen und scheint kredite
nötig waren warum er den besitzer als
politiker nicht publik machte wie es
tschechische gesetze vorschreiben
erklärt er nicht die wähler reagieren
gespalten
das ist doch nur
wenn es wirklich steuerhinterziehung war
sollte man das bestrafen
die tschechische polizei prüft nun die
vorwürfe nichts neues für den
regierungschef denn für sein hotel
storchennest soll er bereits zu unrecht
eu gelder bezogen haben so die eu
kommission
und nun ein neuer skandal
das könnte den unterschied machen es
könnte zugunsten der oppositionspartei
da muss ich schon die wahl ab freitag
wird kaum das ende der politischen
schlammschlacht in tschechien eine
absolute mehrheit erringt wohl keine
partei trotz der skandale hat bahr
beschossen regierungschef zu bleiben
was genau sind die pandora papers wer
hat die unterlagen veröffentlicht und
was steht noch alles drin in der zdf-
heute- app beantworten wir fragen zum
wohl grössten datenleck zu geschäften in
steueroasen
jetzt zur corona lage in deutschland das
robert koch institut meldet 3088 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 66 mehr als vor einer woche die
sieben tage incidents liegt bei 64,7
vollständig gegen korona geimpft sind
64,7 prozent der bevölkerung allerdings
gibt es große unterschiede zwischen den
altersgruppen bei den über 60 jährigen
sind 84,4 prozent vollständig geimpft in
der gruppe 18 bis 59 jahre sind es 70,4
prozent und bei den 12 bis 17 jährigen
liegt die impfquote bei 35 prozent
das berühmte segelschulschiff der marine
die gorch fock ist nach einer
generalüberholung zurück im heimathafen
kiel die sanierung hat sechs jahre
gedauert und rund
135 millionen euro verschlungen fast 14
x mehr als geplant doch nicht nur die
horrenden kosten regen viele auf die
justiz beschäftigt ein vorwurf von
umweltschützern auf dem schiff sei
illegales teak holz verbaut worden aus
kelheim hebestreit
sie schießen salut um die gorch fock
nach
2232 tagen abwesenheit im heimathafen
kiel zu begrüßen damit nimmt eine zeit
voller pleiten pech und pannen für die
marine doch noch ein glückliches ende
immer
wieder schön hier nach kiel zurück zu
kommen und damit letztendlich auch in
unseren angestammten liegeplatz der sind
seit freitag ohne unseren namen trägt da
zu sein und einfach wieder zeugen stück
normalität zurückkehren zu können bei
der marine hatten viele kaum noch daran
geglaubt dass die gorch fock die jeweils
wieder in see stechen würde 2015 waren
im dogma überholung arbeiten schwere
schäden festgestellt worden die kosten
explodierten eine werft pleite
staatsanwälte ermitteln
die steuerzahler müssen jetzt statt
geplanter 10 für das grundsanierte
traumschiff der marine 135 millionen
euro zahlen tendenz steigend die gorch
fock wird auch in zukunft millionen
weiterhin kosten ob das wirklich auch
notwendig ist das muss die marine
beantworten fakt ist jedenfalls dass
dieses projekt völlig aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist
hoch im norden überwiegt die freude dass
ein kieler wahrzeichen zurück ist in
seinem heimathafen ich freue mich dass
sie wieder da ist obwohl ich finde die
kosten sind zu hoch geworden natürlich
spielt geld eine rolle aber da können
wir anfangen im berliner flughafen
stuttgart 21 11 wo wir anfangen wo
aufhören
auch ein vorwurf von umweltschützern auf
dem schiff sei illegal geschlagenes teak
holz verbaut worden beschäftigt die
justiz
davon unbeeindruckt laufen die
vorbereitungen für den ersten
ausbildungstag im winter rund um die
kanaren
bilder von langen staus vor
großbritanniens tankstellen und wütenden
kunden geben seit tagen um die welt nun
soll wie angekündigt das militär die
lage bessern die regierung hatte die
armee angewiesen bei der auslieferung
von treibstoff zu helfen hintergrund des
notstands ist ein eklatanter mangel an
lkw fahrern vorhandener kraftstoff
konnte deshalb nicht zu den tankstellen
gebracht werden hamster und panikkäufe
spitzen die lage zu
nach japan die regierung dort hat die
olympischen spiele durchgezogen gegen
den willen der bevölkerung
tausende corona patienten mussten zu
hause versorgt werden weil die
krankenhäuser überfüllt waren die
wirtschaft lahmt der klimaschutz drängt
richten soll das jetzt der neue
ministerpräsident seit heute ist vom
jupiter im amt der chef der
liberaldemokraten als roller berichtet
japans neuer regierungschef fumiyuki
china tritt ein schweres erbe an die
drittgrösste wirtschaft der welt leidet
unter den folgen der korona krise wie
china will mit einem
investitionsprogramm in milliarden-höhe
den aufschwung schaffen
ich will die löhne erhöhen nicht nur für
bestimmte gruppen sondern für alle
japaner
die japaner sind skeptisch china gehört
der konservativen partei ldp an die
schon lang die politik in japan bestimmt
ganz ehrlich niemand glaubt dass sich
die wirtschaft grundsätzlich verbessert
das vertrauen der japaner in die politik
ist seit der pandemie gesunken auf dem
höhepunkt der krise wurden die
krankenhausbetten knapp ärzte wie
katsumi táchira besuchten damals
sterbenskranke zu hause um sie zu retten
jetzt ist karola zwar nicht mehr so
schön das aber ich mache mir sorgen dass
die regierung wieder anfängt die gefahr
zu unterschätzen
in china war lange außenminister er ist
ein erfahrener konservativer politiker
der als mann der japanischen wirtschaft
gilt und der auf kernenergie im kampf um
klimaneutralität setzt die konservativen
und der politik und in der wirtschaft
glauben fest daran dass die kernenergie
ein teil der energieversorgung in der
zukunft sein auch wenn die japaner
dagegen sind
nun ist fumiyuki china japans neuer
starker mann in einer zeit in der die
pandemie das land verunsichert hat
mit besonderer spannung wurde heute die
bekanntgabe des medizin nobelpreises
erwartet als ein favorit galt die
forschung zum corona impfstoff durch die
jury entschied sich anders für die
beiden us wissenschaftler david julius
und erdem potter putin sie entdeckten
was für uns alle selbstverständlich ist
wie nervenimpulse ausgelöst werden damit
unsere haut auf temperatur und berührung
reagiert thomas garcia hat mehr
eine schlaflose nacht kann so schön sein
nach dem patt apulien neben ihm sein
sohn hat erfahren er bekommt den
nobelpreis auch sein kollege wurde
überrascht
ich habe geschlafen da ich mich an
verwandte an und sagte das komitee kann
deine nummer nicht rausfinden ich dachte
das einen scherz
freude bei wissenschaftlern die
besonders das gegenteil von glück
erforschen den schmerz sie fragten sich
wie genau funktioniert das tasten wie
das füllen von hitze und von schmerz sie
entdeckten an nervenenden bestimmte
sensoren zuständig speziell für diese
reize die ans gehirn weitergegeben
werden eingesetzt haben die forscher
auch den inhaltsstoff von chili schoten
capsaicin
genau den nutzen schmerztherapeuten
bereits etwa bei wund und gürtelrose
provozieren sie gezielt eine
körperreaktion dieser nerven wright
führt zunächst einmal bei unseren
schmerzpatienten zwar zu einer leichten
verstärkung dann aber zu einer
desensibilisierung dieser nerven das
heißt der schmerz wird nach einer
gewissen zeit abheben und das wird der
patient dann als sehr positiv empfinden
schmerz therapie durch gezielte
stimulierende entdeckten sensoren
weitere anwendungen sind denkbar am 10
dezember gibt es den preis für zwei
glückliche genies der sinnes forschung
auf dem gelände des ehemaligen ns
vernichtungslagers auschwitz in polen
ist eine neue ausstellung eröffnet
worden sie beschäftigt sich mit der
rolle von österreichern im zweiten
weltkrieg zur einweihung kamen auch
bundespräsident van der bellen es sei
wichtig zu zeigen dass österreicher
sowohl opfer als auch täter waren
betonte er mehr als zehn jahre lang
haben wissenschaftler daran gearbeitet
die exponate aufzuarbeiten
in die usa die langen strände im süden
von los angeles sind eigentlich ein
beliebter ort um der hektik der mega
metropole zu entfliehen doch im moment
gibt es dort statt hellem sand viel
öligem schlamm nicht weit vor der küste
liegt eine pipeline und verschmutzt das
ökosystem im süden kaliforniens über den
kampf gegen das öl rund um huntington
beach berichtet claudia bates
einsatzteams legen barrieren aus um den
zehn kilometer langen ölteppich
einzudämmen und bedrohte feuchtgebiete
zu schützen
insgesamt liefen rund
570.000 liter aus noch sind sich die
strandbesucher der gesundheitlichen
gefahren gar nicht bewusst sie werden
nun deutlich gewarnt
wir raten den anwohnern dringend
dringend von jeglicher aktivität am
strand kommen sie nicht um zu schwimmen
zu surfen oder um sich zu treffen
das öl trat aus der pipeline in einer
plattform aus die 1980 errichtet wurde
umweltschützer warnen schon lange diese
veralteten plattformen seien zeitbomben
die betroffenen gemeinden wollen die
katastrophe jedenfalls nicht
unbeantwortet lassen
die verantwortlichen ja wir schauen nach
möglichkeiten um sicherzustellen dass
sie zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
das leck wurde inzwischen provisorisch
abgedichtet die auswirkungen auf die
umwelt aber sind wohl unumkehrbar sie
werden noch monate brauchen um hier
alles zu reinigen mit baggern oder mit
eimern manchen hält es einfach nicht zu
hause
wir müssen dieses öl hier weg kriegen
ist schadet der umwelt so sehr sagt
scott white und macht weiter und für
sich und alle hier ein paradies zu
retten
jetzt zu fußball rudi da reiben sich die
bayern fans immer noch unglaublich die
augen ja kein wunder dass bayern münchen
in der bundesliga ein spiel verliert
hatte in den vergangenen jahren
seltenheitswert umso überraschender die
1 2 heimniederlage gegen eintracht
frankfurt bayerns spielverderber an
diesem siebten spieltag stand zwischen
den frankfurter pfosten
torwart kevin trapp ist für die
frankfurter der mann des spiels machtlos
ist er nur beim ersten saisontor von
leon goretzka zur bayern-führung nach 29
minuten doch nach dem ausgleich nur drei
minuten später durch martin hinteregger
erweist sich frankfurts mann im tor als
unbedingt war für die münchner stars mit
denen er im nationalteam derzeit nicht
zusammen spielen darf für bundestrainer
hansi flick als zuschauer im stadion ist
trapp derzeit nur die nummer vier unter
deutschlands torhütern gegen die bayern
hielt er 19 von 20
statistisch gesehen 2010 fünf torschüsse
bis jetzt verdient es nicht ist relativ
egal am ende mehr verloren und fangen
würde jetzt gut gemacht und wir hätten
gewisse dinge besser machen können das 2
1 für die eintracht erzielte der 83
minute philip kostic zum ersten
frankfurter sieg in münchen seit
21 jahren
ja die münchner bleiben tabellenführer
aber bayer leverkusen ist punktgleich
auf dem zweiten platz beim souveränen 4
0 sieg bei arminia bielefeld glänzte die
mannschaft der stunde durch spielfreude
und effektivität ein perfekter
fußballabend für leverkusens junge gerne
selbst leverkusens trainer gerardo
seoane dürfte die momentane klasse
seines teams fast unheimlich sein denn
wie schon unter der woche bei celtic
glasgow wurde auch in bielefeld der
gastgebende verein mit vier zu null
geradezu auseinander genommen muss adia
bis 10 folgten zwei tore von
top-torjäger patrick der sich allerdings
mit seinem ritualisiert mucki torjubel
vor den bielefelder fans keine freunde
machte und bei jedem ballkontakt
gnadenlos ausgepfiffen wurde das
abschließende vier zu null durch einen
von dem ihr bei verwandelten
foulelfmeter kam einer leverkusener
kampfansage an die bayern gleich die in
knapp zwei wochen bei der werkself zu
gast sein werden ja
alle tore und alle partien vom siebten
spieltag können sie sich noch einmal
anschauen wie immer zusammengefasst bei
uns online auf zdf heute.de und in der
zdf- heute so sind sie dann also immer
am ball
war es nur freundschaft oder doch
einiges mehr darüber streiten seit 200
jahren die historiker es geht um marie
antoinette königin von frankreich mit
tragischem ende und den schwedischen
grafen axel von fersen
forschern ist es jetzt gelungen
nachträglich geschwärzte stellen in
ihren briefen zu rekonstruieren heiß
geliebtes da etwa zu lesen das ändert
zwar nichts am lauf der geschichte zeigt
aber auch bei königinnen besiegt die
leidenschaft mitunter die etikette
wenig leidenschaften weg das wetter es
bleibt eher regnerisch mehr dazu gleich
von özden terli christian sievers freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sind danke für ihr
interesse alles gute ihnen und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein stück umarmt und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter noch reißt die serie der
tiefste nicht ab während dieses eine
tiefe allmählich nach nordosten abzieht
kommt schon das nächste und bringt
erneut regen im westen deutschlands jahr
und das hoch richtung russland saß
blockiert immer noch und bleibt auch
noch schauen wir in die nacht unter
müssen wir richtung alpen mit regen
rechnen und auch richtung oder und neiße
sonst im westen lockert es auf und da
gibt es auch mal die sterne zu sehen mit
zwölf grad nach osten hin und 6 grad in
den best deutschen mittelgebirgen 9 grad
gibt es an den alpen und morgen am
vormittag weiter regen richtung süden
nach norden das ganze verlagert sich
allmählich nordostwärts ganz im westen
gibt es sonderschauen aber nicht lange
am nachmittag zieht es auch dort zu mit
dem neuen tief neuer regen und richtung
osten kann es auch mal gewittern mit
höchsten temperaturen bis 22 grad dort
19 grad am niederrhein und 12 grad am
kühlsten an den alpen die kommenden tage
am mittwoch weiterer regen noch mit
dabei bei 10 bis 17 grad danach wird es
allmählich trocken aber den temperaturen
ändert sich kaum etwas ein schöner abend